hi I'm Justine welcome to another
episode of Squatch watch today I really
stepped things up I've got a great team
assembled we've got some new gear and we
are currently in the outskirts of Los
Angeles in the middle of the forest in
the middle of nowhere let's hunt scratch
wash my name is Jenna and I'm here on
Squatch watch I'm an optics engineer
particularly binoculars and other optic
devices like this one here I've been
developing the last 35 years and I'm
really excited about it got a little
lens on there and these bad Larry's
right here I can see any Squatch in the
next six miles I'm gonna hide out for a
minute
use my camera over here now yet hi I'm
Jenna and I am the Sasquatch aficionado
and investigator here today we have a
new briefcase full of gear that will
help us find Sasquatch a magnifying
glass this will be crucial in our feces
finding
[Music]
now you needed me to help you open this
oh sure
thank you spend your knife okay I think
that about does it for our new equipment
let's find Bigfoot I've got some traps
if the new laser technology you
basically can set a perimeter right here
so if anything crosses the laser line
we'll know it's real nice
I know it's missing Bigfoot no food
pretzel didn't Bigfoot might like
pretzels we used to go organic it to
cleanse it you know my legs work into
this and I think we're gonna have to try
the optical hope to go I where do we dig
do we dig here back up back up back up I
got back keep going that's where it's
coming from
dead end we really thought that that is
under there
[Music]
oh god no the sensor Oh No Oh
but you've been here yeah get the kit
get the others shut up
ah he touched it okay
indefinite DNA there I see some
droppings hair follicles definitely
follicles of something nice ah I don't I
don't think so nope I have my own knife
don't worry about it should be good take
this back to the lab good eye you're
seeing had what we call in the biz a
sasquatch seizure you will feel a pain
within your soul let's watch is near
only thing about it is it's incredible
you know really nice work you didn't
work Northwest right okay that's this
way good spot scare was way too heavy
hahaha absolutely all right guys hey
hold on whoa alright it's your call how
do you feel about SWAT calls already
okay been studying it for like 12 years
so good one two three
[Music]
uh-uh I don't hear anything
oh ma Jesse's not out here well next
time right your technology that you
invented and honestly I thought envy it
me too
35 years of work all right we'll keep
looking
[Music]
that was what the evidence camera we
actually
[Music]